come come cazzo ci sono finito qua sotto
so che prima o poi smetterete di
chiedervi quanti fottuti i cappelli o in
casa ma non è questo giorno per la fisi
ragazzi e benvenuti avessero video sono
fa vj e lei siamo tornati su ellaone che
magari se avvio è meglio che mi sono
accorto adesso lo sto registrando
fantastico ma non hai messo la corte
inizio video no perché a volte mi è
capitato di accorgermene a fine video e
vi assicuro che non è stato proprio
bellissima peccato di non aver
registrato quelle scene quando hanno
chiamato la polizia ma ragazzi allora
siamo tornati sui loro nei board perché
penserete tutti quanti visto che
l'ultima volta che ci ho giocato sono
riuscite entrare in quella porta
penserete quindi tutti quanti fa quindi
anno stavo dicendo penserete tutti
quanti che hanno aggiornato il gioco che
si può andare avanti invece non è
cambiato un cazzo e rispetto a prima il
fatto è che molti di voi e avete fatto
solo bene a dirmelo mi hanno detto che
su questo gioco esistono delle cose che
non ho visto tipo questa avete mentito
al fermi in teoria non funzioni entra
ragazzi è stato un bel video e spero vi
sia piaciuto è scusato un secondo devo
cambiare devo cambiare la lingua del
sistema per far funzionare sta roba
e adesso dovrebbe funzionare questa roba
spiega v.no funzionava bene non so
perché devi cambiare la tastiera devi
mettere inglese vabbè però se ti puzza
la madre
[ __ ] ancora quanto e sexy quest'uomo si
è spaventato perché posso usare la
console perché con la consolle caro mio
io posso fare questo kagami telo kleenex
aperte quanto volo su chi posso
bighellonare per aria come se fossi un
uccello meraviglioso cosa cazzo ti
spaventi che non puoi di raggiungermi
pirla cosa vuoi non capiterà una seconda
volta credimi c'è un'altra cosa [ __ ] che
posso fare e si tratta del ghost cioè
fantasma fantasma perché in teoria con
questa cosa puoi fare
questo cioè passare attraverso i muri il
che è una figata pazzesca anche perché
ciò vuol dire che puoi vedere dei posti
che prima non si vedevano perchè ci sono
dei segreti in questo gioco in realtà
che voi non sapete adesso vi faccio lo
zio mi vedi ha forse non mi vede perché
sono un fantasma che figata
e se la ragazza e la tv di leone cane
fifone smettetela di dire che non è così
gli piace leone cane fifone è prodotto
deficiente vabbè comunque la figata di
questo di questa roba qua che poi vedere
cosa che prima non vedevi tipo cazzo ci
fa un manichino qua sotto spiega che
cosa ci fa mani fino a sotto la casa
potere ma cosa c'è un altro vicino
nascosto sotto il pavimento cos'è sta
roba parente questa è l'entrata entry è
sotto l'entrata c'e nascosto un altro
vicino ma perché è un altro armadio
oddio se questa sono io questo ma va va
chi storia ma vanto su brutto o un naso
io che nella vita reale fa veramente
cagare ma zio tu stai messo veramente se
non a barano al contrario frate va beh
comunque in teoria io avrei voluto
vedere visto che sta porta in teoria si
dovrebbe aprire a sono entrato nel poker
addio quindi posso vedere che cosa c'è
oltre la porta fermi porca [ __ ]
io ero arrivato qua una volta arrivato
qua appariva una schermata che ti diceva
continua contributivi perché non c'era
continuo ma io adesso con questa roba
posso andare oltre la porta a a ma alla
fine quindi mio vicino e gay cos'è sta
roba
oddio no ma fermi a questo è quello che
c'è dietro la porta ma che cazzo è che
c'è uno scivolo qua ragazzi fermi sono
emozionatissimo non ero emozionato così
tanto anche quando mi riportavano le
verifiche di matematica col sei
manichini sodio stavano a fuoco qualcuno
afferma non ti vorrei spaventare però
c'è un tuo amico che sta andando a fuoco
non so se lo stai vedendo c'è come
diciamo in piemonte apf dunque una
figata che io riesca a vedere sta roba
cioè una sedia suicida c'è un che chi
cazzo è sta roba ma ragazza ragazzi un
labirinto questo non è una cantina
ancora perché va tutto a fuoco
mi spiegate che problemi mentali al mio
vicino di casa per ridurre casa sua così
avrei capi così ma che c'è una prigione
qua sotto
qualcuno mi spiega perchè soffice
ottiene una prigione fatemi vedere cosa
c'è qua dietro che l'ultima ok a perché
hanno tenuto nascosta questa parte del
gioco se l'anno la lancia fatta così
ampia cioè io ero arrivato veramente qui
e poi si fermava il gioco invece puoi
andare oltre questi trucchi fantastico
ma non ho ancora capito manichini che
bruciano la parte che cosa nasconde sto
tizio quindi dovremo scoprirlo
possibilmente nel prossimo episodio sono
uscita pagare pure il gioco fantastico i
mortacci the two marco ragazzi questi
non erano gli unici comandi che si
possono utilizzare in questo gioco ma ce
ne sono ben altri l'altro comando che
ciò si chiama open
storm è bene dovrebbe aperti dei livelli
tipo nate board tre magliette a quanti
segreti già sto gioco che non ho visto
c'è un'altra casa no ma fermi non saper
c'è una porta e lui o non vedo un cazzo
salve vegas
vabbè ma si sveglia promesso salve
buongiorno e allora è scotti il letto e
di fianco c'è se deve dormire almeno lo
faccia bene era talmente ubriaco la
notte scorsa che è andato a dormire ma
si è sbagliato non si è sdraiato sul
letto la mancato di poco
stupisce cielo prendi la prendi lo zio
prendi la ok o cosi cosi succede perché
sono tornato qua cosa è successo
[Musica]
ma che cazzo ci fai guai a dormire prima
ma se stavi dormendo ma cosa devi uscire
ma dio mio
e vabbè coatte grosso stop e vabbè
lasciamo perdere
[Musica]
devi vuoi dirmi che il tipo non riesce a
raggiungermi perché sono sopra
piedistallo ribelli che c'hai sul tetto
liberati male stavi aspettando per farmi
incazzare di la verità wi fi esplorare
sta a casa maledetta senza rompermi il
cazzo per favore ci mancava solo piano
di sopra guarda questo no questo no è
bello permesso bellissimo un binocolo
c'è il binocolo visto gioco non lo
sapevo neanche ci sono letti una caldaia
come ci arriva la sopra aiuto su
scalando sono tipo ezio auditore non
riescono arrampicati sul cavo non ci
arrivo frate forse no uccidere questo
attaccapanni non è stato il massimo
della vita ghost ma non abbassava il fly
che pirla la madonna cos'è chiamerà di
sicurezza un piede di porco asso tutti
gli oggetti anche telefono bellissimo la
palla da basket leggre dai questa
istanza meno male almeno quello
bellissimo certo ma guarda la fisica la
conosci perfettamente bravo videogioco
hai sbagliato leggermente a metterla sul
muro a posizionarla dico prof
vabbè lavora ghazi in teoria crede di
aver visto tutto visto livello qua a
parte il fatto che non ho capito da dove
arrivi l'altro l'altro vicino perché
l'ho perso completamente di vista fuochi
d'artificio giusto intro map che c'è
dentro up a noi il menu principale va
bene open in trovato abbiamo visto le
belluno nei menu va beh almeno un
principale net worth revel uno deve
l'uno sarebbe è questo a no niente ok
vabbè ragazzi è arrivato il momento di
provare questo che vuole provarlo
dall'inizio che change size e mettiamo
tipo 7
sì volevo vorresti prendermi brutto
straw non ti rendi conto che se
leggermente in svantaggio per le severe
mese vi è grata radar after tartara mi
piaci giachino che oggi può accompagnare
solo il terzo è bello bellissimo in
terza persona mi vedo le caviglie
meno male che non ai risvolti ni change
and science uno ok allora sono veramente
io mi sono visto in terza per cosa
faccio cos'è salve sono il nuovo vicino
vengo ad inchinarmi a lei io ti odio
vicino di merda è la madonna 10 quant'è
porcaccia butta mille promettere secondo
me che lascia al gioco proprio lo stesso
change size mille va bene ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto a meno vi ho fatto
vedere tutto quello che per adesso il
gioco aspettiamo il prossimo
aggiornamento per fare altre minchiate
together per i ragazzi si spara nei vini
sia piaciuto in cui gli episodi come
asserito ragazzi se video piaciuto
segmento è un mi piace anche ai vari
social che come livido trattenersi
iniziare ricordatevi di lasciare laiche
sono faccio change side su di me mi
faccio sheikh said 10 e vengo a
schiaffeggiare viziose la city 16v
diavolo prossimo video e da ragazzi